I played Starfield for 20 hours so far
here are my quick pros and cons Pro it
is the least buggy Bethesda game I have
ever played they clearly took some extra
time to polish this one and it shows con
exploration in general is really limited
this one's a bummer for me because I
love exploring in Bethesda games like
just walking in a direction and not
knowing what crazy Quest I'm gonna come
across Starfield does have a lot of
planets most of them are empty and will
not have any quests on them whatsoever
and even the planets that do have quests
they're all really contained to one
location from everything I've seen Pro
the companions are a lot of fun and
super diverse like such different
personalities to pick from also an
incredible voice acting cost I just
genuinely liked spending time with all
the companions con-ish while it is I
think bethesda's best gun play yet the
shooting still doesn't feel quite as
good to me as other games in the genre
bro the base building and ship
customization are just as extensive as
you would hope shipbuilding is actually
a little bit tough to get into initially
base billing is just like Fallout
another potential con I think the game
takes a really long time to get into
regardless